Speaker 1: Hey, David, is there anyone who
would run against Trump in the Republican
primary instead of letting him have the nomination
if he wants it?
This is a great question.
The context is that last week, former ambassador
to the U.N. Nikki Haley said even though at
one point a couple of months ago she was kind
of critical of Trump, she said, if Trump runs,
I wouldn't run in twenty, twenty four.
And if Trump runs, I would support Donald
Trump.
I think most of the people right now that
are contenders for the Republican primary
in 2024 would get the hell out of the way
and let Trump have it.
It just took Mike Pompeo, Trump's secretary
of state, as mentioned.
I don't even think Pompeo is a candidate,
but there's no there's no chance in hell that
Pompeo runs against Donald Trump.
If I was thinking about it and Trump runs
Pompeo out of the way, I don't think Mike
Pence would run against Donald Trump.
That would be really weird.
Former vice president running against the
person they served under.
Don't think it's going to happen.
Ron, to this is being mentioned, the Republican
Florida governor, who is horrible in every
way he would not run against Donald Trump.
Um, Josh Hawley, who was one of the first
defiantly and and proudly opposing the certification
of the twenty twenty election results.
He's not running against Trump, Ted Cruz not
running against Trump.
Kristi Noem, the South Carolina governor,
she's a Trump suck up.
She's not going to run against them.
Lindsey Graham, forget about it.
A Rick Scott.
I don't see any of these people actually challenging
Trump unless something dramatic were to happen
around the twenty, twenty two midterms.
I think that the people who would stay in
if Trump runs.
Are the people who would be running because
they don't like Trump, people like Mitt Romney,
who else?
I don't even know.
I can't even think of anybody else.
Mitt Romney types are the ones that wouldn't
get out of the way for Trump because they
are not Trump's fundamentally.
And I think that Trump's 20 24 future will
be far more determined by Trump's physical
health at the time and whether Trump's urge
for revenge and pettiness override laziness.
And I think that Trump spending four years
at Mar a Lago, the idea of of I mean, you
know, the campaign fuels his narcissism, the
crowds and the speeches and the media coverage.
There's no doubt about it.
But at the same time, he's not a particularly
healthy guy.
He'll be close to 80 at that time.
I think he will be relatively bored and complacent.
And it will really be Trump who determines
what happens in 2024 as of right now, if it
if it's Trump versus Romney today, I think
Trump certainly wins.
Trump has the support of the vast majority
of the Republican Party, but don't expect
the challenge to Trump by anyone from within
the Trump circle.
Could could Liz Cheney maybe challenge Trump?
Yeah, maybe somebody like that.
Condoleezza Rice?
I don't know.
I'm thinking out loud, but most of the people
that have been around Trump are not going
to challenge Donald Trump if Donald Trump
decides
to run.